Transcriber: yasser mohamed
المدقّق: Nada Mostafa
السلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته.
أهلاً و سهلاً بكم أعزائنا المشاهدين
من مسرح تيدكس شهار،
نتمنى لكم أوقاتًا سعيدة.
أعزائنا المشاهدين من هذه الجملة تحديدًا
تبدأ حكايتكم مع "التضليل الإعلامي".
حيث لا يوجد أي عزيز علي قلب المذيع
سوى من يخصه من ذويه.
مرحبا! أنا حسن رحماني،
أعمل في روتانا خليجية
أعمل في مجال الإعلام حوالي منذ عشر سنوات.
أحب هذا المجال جدا..
أحب هذا المجال؛ لأنه يشعرني بالقوة.
لأنه يجعلني أُسهم في صناعة الرأي العام.
وتوجيه الرأي العام.
يجعلني أُسهم في صناعة رأيك أنت.
وصناعة رأيِك أنتِ أيضًا وتوجيهكم جميعًا.
أعلم جيدًا،
أن هذا الشعور مزعج
للكثير من الناس،
ولكنه في المقابل،
هو شعور لذيذ لكل الإعلاميين.
يعلم الإعلاميون المنتصرون تحديدًا،
هذا الشعور،
ولذة هذا الشعور.
الإعلاميون المنتصرون علي الجمهور،
وليس المنتصرون له!
قد يتساءل البعض
لماذا أنا أقف علي هذه المنصة العالمية.
هناك سببان؛
السبب الأول، هو هذا الوطن الشامخ.
الذي يستحق..
(تصفيق)
السبب الأول هو هذا الوطن الشامخ
الذي يستحق أن نذود عنه بكل ما نملك،
من معرفة.
يستحق أن نذود عنه بكل ما نملك،
المعرفة هي جزء مما نملك
أما السبب الثاني فهو
أنتم معشر حضور تيد إكس،
إذ أثبتت إحدي الدراسات العالمية،
في معهد "هافيلاند كارير" الأمريكي
والمتخصص في العلوم الإنسانية،
أن من يهتمون بحضور مؤتمرات تيد إكس
حول العالم يفوقون أقرانهم ذكاءًا
بنسبة 9.2% علي مستوي العالم.
(لا يوجد معهد باسم هافيلاند
كارير للعلوم الإنسانية)
إذا، هافيلاند كارير هو
مخترع المكيف فقط!
وهذا التنبيه،
لن تحصل عليه أبدًا من أي وسيلة إعلام.
لن تمنحك إياه أي صحيفة.
هذا التنبيه فقط يجب أن يكون داخلك أنت.
هناك ثلاثة شروط، لنجاح عملية التضليل
كما يراها "هربرت شيللر"
في كتابه "المتلاعبون بالعقول"
يعتقد هربرت شيللر أنه أهم شرط
من شروط، نجاح عملية التضليل،
هو إخفاء شواهد التضليل، يجب أن يشعر
المضَلَّل أن كل ما حوله يمضي كما هو عليه.
شروط التضليل:
أولًا، جهل المضَلَّل التام.
ثانيًا، الثقة التامة
أو الموثوقية والمقبولية للجهة المضلِّلة.
وما أكثر الجهات التي نثق بها!
ثالثًا، وهو شرط مهم جدًا،
وهو أنت،
قابليتك للتضليل.
قابليتك للتضليل عزيزي المشاهد، تكون على
مستوى الأفراد وتكون على مستوى الجماعات.
لن يستطيع المضلِّل اختراقك،
ما لم تكن لديك هذه القابلية.
هذه القابلية إذا كانت على مستوى الأفراد،
فهي بسبب قلة الوعي.
وإن كانت على مستوى الجماعات..
فهي بسبب التفكك والخلخلة في المجموعات.
هناك طريقتان للتضليل..
يعني ما أقصد طريقتان تحديدًا،
هناك ثلاث طرق للتضليل.
الطريقة الأولى من الثلاثة طرق..
هي ليست طريقتان، وليست ثلاثة طرق.
هناك أكثر من ثلاثين طريقة وتكتيك،
لاقتحام العقول..
للسيطرة.. لزراعة المعتقدات، وزعزعة
القناعات، لاقتيادنا إلى حيث يريد المضلِّل.
الكثير والكثير من هذه التكتيكات،
إغراق المجتمع بالمعلومات الزائدة،
أو ما يسمى بالنفايات المعلوماتية،
القولبة، التنميط كل هذه التقنيات سنشاهدها.
في فيديو سريع.
كل هذه التقنيات واكثر،
تمارس بشكل يومي علينا،
تمارس دون أن ندرك.
خطورة التضليل لا تكمن في
الكذب بالشكل المباشر.
خطورة التضليل تكمن في عدم قول الحقيقة،
تكمن في التلاعب بالمصطلحات،
في هذه التقنيات جميعًا.
الصورة وحدها فقط هي من تدحض
كل تلك الحجج.
اللغة المستخدمة سابقًا في كل التقنيات،
تدحضها فقط هذه الصورة.
هذه الصورة فقط
هي من يستطيع من خلالها فقط..
الصورة أيضًا تكذب،
حاول، حاول إنك ما تضلل الناس.
ركز على البرزنتيشن.. أوكي؟
شكرًا
(تصفيق)
الصورة أيضًا تكذب
الفيديو يكذب،
الصحف تكذب،
المذياع يكذب،
تم السطو بكل ما هو من حولك،
تم السطو بكل ما تقرأ، وما تشاهد، وما تسمع.
ولكن، كيف تتم الهيمنة على كل هؤلاء الناس؟
تتم الهيمنة من خلال ما ذكرته لكم،
واغتصاب الوعي من خلال ما ذكرته لكم.
من التقنيات السابقة.
ولكن هل هذه التقنيات السابقة،
هي ارتجالية واعتباطية؟
أبدًا!
ليست ارتجالية أو اعتباطية.
أبدًا،
هي مدروسة بعناية فائقة.
ولكن قبل أن أخبركم عن مؤسسي هذه التقنيات،
سأخبركم عن شيء آخر، ينتمي لهذه التقنيات.
وهي ما يسمى، بأسطورة الحياد.
إحدى أشهر الأسلحة، أو أحد أشهر الأسلحة
التي يشهرها التضليل في وجه الجمهور.
أسطورة الحياد، والإيهام بالمهنية،من خلال
طرح الخبر كما هو، والتلاعب بالتعليق.
من خلال وضع خصمين على طاولة الخلاف،
وطرح قضاياهما بدعوى الرأي والرأي الآخر.
وفي الحقيقة،
بدعوى ضرب الرأي بالرأي الآخر.
هل تعرفون برنامجًا يقدم شيء كهذا الأمر.
أحد يذكرني هو الإتجاه المخاف،
أو مخالفة الإتجاه، معاكسة
حاجة زي كده بس أنا مش فاكر.
أيًا يكن، هذا البرنامج من أسوأ ما يمكن أن
يظهر على الشاشة في مواضيع التضليل الإعلامي
ماذا يفعل هذا البرنامج ببساطة..
ضيفين لا يتقاطعان في أي نقطة التقاء
وعادة ما يكونان من نفس المجتمع.
يطرحان قضيتهما،
يكشفان أجندتهما لبعض
المشكلة ليست في هذين الطرفين المتناقرين،
المشكلة الحقيقة في أتباعهما..
الذين عادةً هم بالملايين،
وعادةً من نفس المجتمع.
ما هي النتيجة المرجوة،
بعد حلقة من هذا البرنامج.
سوى التشظي في المجتمع،
سوى الانتصالية في المجتمع.
وهذا أقصى ما تريده هذه القناة،
وهذا البرنامج.
وهي اغتيال الأمن في نفوس المجتمعات،
والشعوب.
"إدورد بيرنيز" صاحب الشنب الظريف.
تذكروا هذا الاسم جيدًا،
"إدورد بيرنيز"، مؤسس التضليل الإعلامي،
والأب الروحي لهذا العلم الأسود،
في كل أنحاء العالم.
"إدورد بيرنيز" هو مخترع البروباجندا
"إدورد بيرنيز" هو مؤسس البيان الصحفي.
لأنه كان يرى
أن الخبر،
وليس الإعلان ما يصل للجمهور.
أو ما يوصل الرسالة للجمهور،
بشكل لا يقبل التشكيك.
"إدورد بيرنيز" قدم شيء لهذا العالم.
قد نتفق أو قد نختلف عليه، ولكن
كل الجهات التي تريد السيطرة على العالم
يجب أن يكون مرجعها الأول هذا الرجل.
دعوني أخبركم شيءً بعيدًا عن "إدورد بيرنيز"
بحكم أنه مات زمان.
كل ما ذكرته لكم سابقًا، خلوه على جنب.
انسوا موضوع التضليل الكلاسيكي السابق تمامًا.
كل التقنيات التي تحدثنا عنها،
اتركوها جانبًا.
أنت عزيزي المشاهد الآن على
خط المواجهة مع أخطر تضليل في هذا الكون
أنت الآن على خط المواجهة مع خوارزميات
الذكاء الاصطناعي.
لن أتحدث كثيرًا عن الذكاء الاصطناعي،
نتابع الفيديو هذا، ربما البعض تابعه
واللي ما تابع، يتابع الآن؛
لأنه سيكون صدمة.
14 ساعة استخدمت،
من أجل فقط إصدار دقيقة واحدة،
يتحدث بها الرئيس السابق الأمريكي،
"أوباما"
إن الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي أصبح يشكل
خطورة بالغة
التطبيق الذي انتشر مؤخرًا،
"FaceApp" ، الكل يعرفه.
لن أتحدث عن ما تحدث عنه الجميع،
من أخذ المعلومات وشيء من هذا أبدًا.
لكن سأحدثكم عن شيء مهم جدًا.
الكل يراهن على جودة هذا البرنامج،
الكل يملك هذا البرنامج،
من من ليسوا محترفين في هذا الذكاء.
إذا المحترف، ماذا سيصنع؟
المتمكن من هذا البرنامج، ومن هذا العلم،
ما الذي يستطيع أن يفعله مع هذا العالم؟
إذًا، السؤال المهم.
ماذا نستطيع أن نصنع،
إزاء هذه الحرب الناعمة؟
ماذا بيدنا؟
حقيقةً، لن تجدوا لدي إجابة.
أنا هنا فقط لأثير المخاوف.
أنا هنا فقط؛ لأخبركم أنكم في مأزق.
لكن هذا لا يمنع أن نأخذ بنصيحة
أحد سادة التضليل في هذا العالم.
الوزير، وزير الإعلام النازي السابق،
في الحرب العالمية الثانية، "جوزيف جوبلز"
الذي كان يقول:
"كلما سمعت كلمة مثقف، وضعت يدي على مسدسي"
"جوبلز" كان يثق تمامًا ويعي جيدًا،
أن المثقف الحقيقي
أحد أهم عناصر مكافحة التضليل،
في هذا العالم.
يدرك جيدًا، أن المعرفة الجادة
إحدى الأدوات التي تكسر حدة
موجة التضليل في العالم.
هناك عدة آليات للإحتماء من هذه الكارثة.
سأخبركم عن آلية واحدة فقط.
ومن أراد الاستزادة، فلديه فرصة البحث.
عليك دائمًا التأكد من وجود أكثر من مصدر.
متناقضة المصالح، تبث نفس الخبر.
عليك التأكد دائمًا من وجود أكثر من مصدر،
متناقضة المصالح، تبث ذات الخبر.
أعزاءنا المشاهدين،
يعز علي كثيرًا أن أخبركم بأننا نعيش
في بيئة، ومجتمع،
وعالم مشبع بالتضليل الإعلامي
ولكنها الحقيقة.
حذاري عزيزي المشاهد من الاعتقاد لوهلة،
أن العلاقة بينك وبين وسائل الإعلام،
هي علاقة تواصل.
لا، بل هي علاقة توجيه!
وعلاقة سيطرة!
حذاري كل الحذر، أن تعتقد هذا الأمر.
ولذلك، حاول، حاول
بقدر ما تستطيع أن لا تكون الطرف الأضعف،
في هذه العلاقة.
وإلى هنا أعزاءنا المشاهدين، نكون قد وصلنا
معكم إلى نهاية فقرتنا لهذه الليلة.
تقبلوا تحيات فريق العمل،
والسلام عليكم ورحمة الله تعالى وبركاته.
(تصفيق)